do you think there's other universes
besides our own
those sort of well-defined theories
which make assumptions
about the physics at the relevant time
and this time incidentally is 10 to the
power minus 36 seconds um or earlier
than that so this tiny sliver of time
and um there are some theories uh famous
one due to andre linday um the russian
now at stanford called eternal inflation
um which did predict um
an internal production of new big bangs
as it were and uh
that's based on specific assumptions
about the physics but those assumptions
of course are just hypotheses which
aren't vindicated but there are other
theories which
only predict one big bang so i think
we should be open-minded and not
dogmatic about these these options until
we do understand the relevant physics
but there are these different scenarios
or very different ideas about
about this but i think all of them have
the
feature
that physical reality is a lot more
extensive than what we can see through
our telescope i think even most
conservative astronomers would say that
because
we can see out without telescopes to a
sort of horizon
which is about
depending on how you measure it by maybe
15 billion light years away or something
like that but that horizon of our
observations
is no more physical reality
than the horizon around you if you're in
the ocean
and look at looking out at your horizon
there's no reason to think that the
ocean ends just beyond your horizon and
likewise there's no reason to think that
the aftermath of our big bang
um ends
just
at the boundary for we can see indeed
there are quite strong arguments um that
it probably goes on about 100 times
further
it may even go on so much further
that uh all combinatorials are
replicated and uh there's another set of
people like us sitting in a in a room
like this every possible combination of
yeah
that could happen
well that's not logically impossible um
but but i think many people would accept
that it does go on um and
contain um
probably a million times as much stuff
as what we can see within the horizon
the reason for that incidentally is that
if we look as far as we can in one
direction and in the opposite direction
then the conditions don't differ
by more than one part in a hundred
thousand so that means that if we're
part of some finite structure
the gradient across the part we can see
is very small and so that suggests that
it probably does go on a lot further and
the best estimates say it must go on at
least 20 times further
is that
exciting or terrifying to you just the
spans of it all the wide
everything that lies beyond the horizon
that example doesn't even hold for earth
so it goes way way farther and on top of
that just to take your metaphor further
with the on the ocean yeah while we're
on top of this ocean
not only can we not see beyond the
horizon
we also don't know much about the depth
of the ocean
nor the actual mechanism of observation
that's in our head yes
no i think there's another is all those
points you make yes yes but but i think
um uh
even
even the solar system is pretty vast by
human standards and so uh i don't think
the perception of this utterly vast
cosmos
um
need have any
deeper impact on us than just realizing
that we are
very small on the scale of the external
world
yeah
it's humbling though
it's it's humbling
in uh depending where your ego is it's
humbling and well if you speak very
unhumble indeed it may make a difference
but for most of us i don't think it
makes it much difference and uh well
there's a more general question of
course about uh um whether um the human
race as such
is something which is
very special
or if on the other hand um it's just one
of
many such
species elsewhere in the universe or
indeed existing at different times in
our universe
you